pakistan is drowning the raging monsoon
has already claimed over a thousand
lives
and still
the waters keep coming
a lot of flood water entered our village
our homes are submerged some of our
relatives have died and cattle too we
are not receiving any relief from the
government
millions of people are affected as flash
flooding has washed away entire villages
and crops that in turn has raised fears
of food shortages even as the
authorities grapple with the immediate
problems of evacuating the worst-hit
areas and providing shelter to the
displaced
pakistan is an agricultural country sin
punjab and pakistan are the most
important provinces for agriculture its
areas grow cotton and rice all these
three have been affected by floods in
the coming season the farmers won't have
seed to the next crops there isn't even
enough to feed people in the short term
july in pakistan was the wettest in 30
years the government has called it a
climate catastrophe pakistan has been
ranking in the top 10 most vulnerable to
climate change for the last couple of
years now and there and their reasons
for it include a large population and
then very eclectic topography including
rivers and the sea and then we have
glaciers this time the monsoon rains
were erratic they were unprecedented the
kind of rainfall that was received we
really couldn't have planned for it the
government couldn't have planned for it
the uk the us and others have already
contributed to a disaster appeal but
more international aid is urgently
needed
even then pakistan faces a turbulent few
months in deep and treacherous waters
matthew thompson sky news